[Applaudissements]
by claude c'est parti
attention
je la connais depuis tout petit
à cause d'elle j'ai tardé on pouvait
rester des heures ensemble sans parler
elle me racontait des histoires j'avais
des étoiles plein les yeux
maintenant que j'ai grandi je sais
qu'elle me mentais un peu ma mère
ledyard est elle voit 30 bêtes ceux qui
la connaissent trop bien prennent
solange la grosse tête
cultivée elle efface mes idées noires
elle me parle de la nature de la musique
du cinéma elle peut me faire croire
n'importe quoi
infréquentable elle aime les chiffres et
les mots de chic elle veut que tout le
monde la regarde
j'suis pas influençable crois pas que
c'est elle qui les éduquent elle à cette
sale manie de vouloir me vendre des
trucs de l'hôpital à la prison quoi
qu'il arrive elle sera là elle se
dévoile un peu les premiers samedis soir
de chaque mois elle est comme ça est
fait le show elle par laurie un image ne
veut pas lui en vouloir quand elle met
trop de maquillage mc blague quand elle
dit des choses qui me concerne j'ai pu
temps pour elle depuis que je fais des
concerts
elle est folle mais c'est un comme elle
est belle depuis que mon père a plus
tard il passe ses journées avec elle
gros carnet d adresses elle connaît tout
paris elle danse avec la nouvelle star
veut gagner 30 millions d'amis je la
mettrai jamais sous scellés elle est
complexe et un peu fêlé elle c'est ma
télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo
des trucs qui sont avait tourné toute
verte ultra les verts très fort
dallest j'ai connu pas d'accord je l
adore merci aux céréales ils proton à ta
place et du parc de téléphones et tu
pars également avec ta femme c'est pour
moi décalé au vertige merci bravo
monsieur olivier choc avec les séries
mondiales à ce qu ils sont libres est
avec nous bravo les gars étaient ici